what's going on reject nation guten tag
we are going to watch from looper from
uh
in regards to the boys what stormfront
really said
at the end of the boys season two so if
you're not caught up with the boys
you're gonna
to leave this video right away because
[ __ ] got incinerated and then she said
some stuff in german
and we have no idea what she said when
that scene
started the first thought i had was
there's going to be a video break in
this day
here it is if you haven't seen any of
our boys reactions all the reaction
highlights are up
on youtube right now i want to say a
special thank you to everyone
who had gone and followed us over at our
patreon page your support means a lot so
many of you guys have been doing the
watch alongs with us and checking out
all those other shows and
considering that about half of the
youtube cuts are not monetized
really does make up for a lot of that so
thank you guys so much
anywho let's check this out
on the boys season 2 finale stormfront
learns a very important lesson
never attempt to kill a junior soup's
mom right in front of them
after receiving a beating from kimiko
starlight and queen
that's a great scene girls get it done
butcher from taking ryan to safety
unfortunately for stormfront seeing
someone choking his mom is enough to
trigger
ryan's powers but he uses his heat
vision to blast off her limbs
leaving her seemingly near death and
babbling in german
given what fans know about storm france
it would seem safe to assume she was
felting nazi rhetoric
but thanks to reddit's user radiotan
stormfront's final words for season two
at least
herlander insists she's still alive in
an undisclosed location
have been revealed to be surprisingly
human according to radiotan
stormfront says this at the end of the
boys season two finale
translate to english as it was so
beautiful how the three of us sat there
in the shade of an apple tree
do you remember the day frederick chloe
had her arm stretched out of the car
window
he found the perfect spot by the river
in the shade of an apple tree it was the
first time chloe ate fresh apples
later when home told her
in english that means i was so happy it
was wonderful
i never wanted it to end it would appear
that in what stormfront believes to be
her final moments
she doesn't think back to her hateful
beliefs or the atrocities that she's
committed
instead she remembers a quiet day with
her husband and daughter
and she yearns to return to what she
sees as a simpler time
at first translation
attempting to humanize a truly
despicable person but in truth
stormfront's final words both reinforce
the strong theme of family that runs
throughout season two
and also act as a reminder of just how
twisted her world view is
storm friends may remember an idyllic
day of lounging under an apple tree as a
perfect picture family moment
but in reality she and her husband are
fighting for mass genocide and hateful
racist ideas
whether she calls herself all about
perspective talk about perspective
priorities right from the beginning of
season two
she shows her hand storm franz wants to
recreate the past
which for her means the early days of
nazi germany so it only makes sense that
she would retreat there while in a state
of shock
in an interview with variety showrunner
eric kripke discussed how the boys
season 2 puts the idea of family ties
right at the center whether it was
butcher confronting just how similar he
is to his father
or stormfront reminiscing to starlight
about her mother adele the relationships
between parents and their children was a
recurring theme throughout the season
but kripke having ryan rather than
kimiko or starlight to be the one to end
stormfront's reign of terror was about
bringing that theme
full circle he said what we kept coming
back to is that we really needed to
demonstrate how powerful ryan was
and still have starlight and kimiko and
maeve get a certain
visceral satisfaction with what they're
doing but half the final ending be
really wrenching and emotional and
personal i think you guys knocked it out
of the park man you did it
it's a success well family and the
question of can they survive it
you just try things and that felt like
it really resonated the most
ultimately kripke described butcher's
dad as a demon on his shoulder
and becca as his humanity thankfully for
ryan the butcher's humanity wins out
when he decides to keep his promise to
protect the boy
for the moment butcher's resisting it's
a boy
and he's hoping that thanks to becca's
influence ryan will be able to do the
same where homelander ryan's biological
father
is concerned eventually everything comes
back to the theme of family and the boys
even for characters as monstrous as
stormfront and homelander
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe you know what just hit me
adjusting me watching this footage is
stormfront's a nazi
stormfront is racist
no in season one homelander took
butcher's wife and then at the end of
season two
butcher takes homelanders kit
full circle right there never never put
that together
i mean it was all obviously yeah but i
never drew that kind of
but when it yeah when parallel and
switching clicks in your mind
have that little emotional moment yeah i
mean the basic summation
of what stormfront was going back to was
a peaceful memory
with uh frederick and chloe i actually
think that is great yeah not because a
supporter believes i'm saying that in
terms of
character writing you know and and like
in a show like this you're constantly
looking for easter eggs and such and
this is really just comes down to uh
a place of someone who speaks german who
can translate right literally
yes some people might chalk it up to
trying to humanize the character
and i think it is actually kind of that
i would push back against that there's
some people were saying it's not really
about that which which is true i mean
it's really going in tune with the
the themes of family that this season
really represents
however i do think that it does make her
character more human at the same time so
maybe the intent isn't to
humanize her but in terms of really
fleshing this human being out that does
make this character more human because
she could have just had her last words
just be like some evil adolf hitler's or
something
we'll all see yeah these other filthy
racists
or something right yeah but this took
the approach of
she really did think her point of view
was right
you know there's that line where she's
talking to ryan which
was like a shocking line and then had a
great reaction from homelander when she
talks about white genocide yeah
why genocide right yeah yeah it's like
oh my god i can't believe you're going
there and even homelanders looking at
her like
oh ridiculous kid right here hold on
crazy but then it has you kind of think
back on that
for me like actually hearing this makes
me go into a different perspective of
she really thought she was a hero
i thought she was doing something good
for the world and maybe that's not
what's being communicated here but the
fact that her mind goes back to that
that relationship that dynamic and who
she was as a as a younger person
especially with the core beliefs that
she shared
with frederick that really just goes to
amplify oh man everything she ever
talked about was
when she talked about like you know uh
white gen
anything that dealt with white genocide
and other races like she believed that
in a sincere version of
i'm a human trying to fight for the
right things and she had this element of
love within her it's just all thwarted
in all these other different colors
it's just corrupted by so many terrible
and i mean yeah i think it it speaks to
something interesting and it's a
an important line i think to draw
between making a character more human
humanizing a character versus making a
character sympathetic yeah exactly
that's exactly what i was going to get
at yeah because it makes her more of
a believable person you know yeah cause
you believe then there there's a nuance
and you
wonder what you know aspired this part
of you
and how did you get so far away from
that into these other modes of hatred
yeah for me just as a viewer i'm really
happy that that's
you know the kind of moment they gave
her because i think nowadays especially
the
thing like that in a show if there's
some other language with no subtitles
immediately it's an easter egg
yeah uh but yeah i i feel like you know
for the people who are going to jump in
and do that research i do think
yeah it enriches the show because it
does show you that as much as this
character is hateable
it makes it more poignant in a fictional
universe if that character isn't just
a cartoon and i mean yes the boys is a
graphic novel it is a cartoon in a lot
of ways
but that lends credence to both the
themes of family but also just yeah
these as
characters you can get invested in and
that's part of the tragedy too is
because you know there are moments
and it's you know a credit to her
performance too there are these moments
where she'll get lost in what she's
talking about and that
love will come out for you know like
what she and friedrich shared and what
they believed in
in those earlier episodes especially
before she's like overtly being like
nazi stuff you see that twisted
conviction that
is the sort of barrier that fascinates
me about real life it's like
you have people out there who just
believe in these convictions that are so
rooted in these hatred and
misunderstandings and yet that's just
like to them that's the way
like that this is the way it's a good
moment to show that because this is a
show that delights in that this is the
show that'll have homeland or do these
horrible terrible things but then like
when he's bonding a little bit like
trying to parent ryan you're a little
bit like
okay but i i want you to do a good job i
guess if you're doing it and there are
moments of this that are charming
because like yeah
it's it's the nuance of the show
exemplified i think we're tying it back
into the parenting
aspect because you get so much of that
throughout there was one episode in
particular i don't remember exactly
which one it was but i remember that was
like the thing we kicked off the review
with
of talking about how this one really
felt like it was about parenting while
you do get some of that
with the storm front um in doses
throughout this
season you know learning her backstory
you don't cut to a flashback with her or
you don't see her
interact with her actual family
but frederick or chloe and this is the
closest you get so what i think in terms
of filmmaking that makes this such a
a great nugget to throw in here is that
when it first shows up on screen because
you know her her backstory is slowly
unraveling people learn that she's
really a nazi but you don't see her
speaking in german she comes across
very american when she's all burnt to a
crisp and she's going back to like you
know her brain is all now functioning
and then she's spewing words in german
it's actually very
unsettling because it feels like oh my
god we're this is the nazi yeah yeah
it's like that's oh she's always been
the nazi but this is the nazi so it's
actually very
uncomfortable and eerie yeah and then
when you
learn what it is you're like oh man it's
not just a hate speech
you know yeah and then also i think
that's great i think that's like really
clever writing
yeah yeah and there's something i think
about german gets
slagged as a language for not being as
beautiful
exactly it's like german and just
immediately i think
go to that and that's also just an
interesting thing to note about
people and that's a human nuance because
yeah like one of the few times if the
only time she speaks german is yet to
recite something that's
beautiful you know which is the ult like
irony
all right guys what do you think about
this translation do you think it helps
elevate
that scene knowing what she actually
said i wonder if we could go to the
comments and there's a whole bunch of
german people being like that as long as
you said yeah
so yeah
[Laughter]
love to all of our german viewers
people love it when we do their accent
subscribe
click that notification bell thanks
again everyone follow us on our patreon
give looper some love as well
last but not least
i'd like to shout out my friend jason
dolan it's gonna be kind of a two-parter
shout out here because
jason dolan has been working hard
to help out cazzy reacts producer editor
for the channel as well
recently put together this movie
reaction for uh
joker which i watched the whole thing
it's great like in terms of editing
wonderful job in terms of cassie's
performance wonderful job i did put a
post out about it on the community page
and a lot of you guys already went over
there
show both editing and kazzy some love
and please if you haven't seen it yet
i think it's really well worth it it's
very she's very emotionally gripped yes
throughout
no idea what to expect it made for a
very raw
vulnerable reaction really well put
together and i think if you guys are
a fan of joker even if you just thought
it was okay if you just like reactions i
think you'll really enjoy that video
it's a very sincere one
so yeah check it out there'll be a link
in the description box for it
see you guys